first of all gentlemen hmm let's have a
little chat about paragon which is game
does exactly that little shrug you made
that's what i would say every time
someone said bag on to me it sort of
existed in that in that coin Chris
waters that melange of MOBA overwatch
battle bore and battle cry pack it was
all kind of in there together but the I
guess the the closed Alfred still closed
at the moment so I think they're opening
it up later in spring we got access to
it a couple of days ago and I've been
playing a lot of it and then I'm
actually kind of super into it for
somebody who's never really been into
moments but who loves games like unreal
tournament so I want to kind of ask you
guys about this as well because we've
all kind of played it I don't even
played a bit of it today or yeah and
like how much have you played a part on
I played a few hours probably around
eight total I did the preview event for
it a couple weeks ago and then I played
a little bit once we had the access and
yeah I like it it's it's definitely like
starts from like epics action roots like
the third person action you know like
which they're known for and yeah it
translates really well it's definitely a
MOBA more even more than like battle
born has that one incursion mode which
we also have access to now but we
haven't been able to get any matches um
but this is very much like a MOBA but in
third person yes like very action
focused is a it is one map there are
three lanes there are towers who knocked
down there is a core you need to explode
and it's five you five as well yeah and
it has some element of shop in it as
well in the card packs it's God jungle
which in this case is a forest which you
were saying has most of its textures
have yet to grow yeah it says like alpha
it's an alpha so don't worry about the
mobs you know they're they're gonna look
better probably you know they're just
kind of shells of what you would fight
in a jungle but yeah it as all intensive
purposes is a traditional you know MOBA
yes except for third person I guess so
except for third person I guess also the
thing that is different between this and
most mobile games is that most mobile
games isometrically your most of your
targets are getting locked on so you're
like attacking people and then basically
triggering attacks like you would and
you know the root of those games games
like Warcraft or one or games like
Diablo or whatever where is this game
you're basically shooting like you
in any other third person shooter so
feels like like it is already kind of
feels like when you were playing third
person parts of Unreal Tournament like
the way it control is like maybe you're
in vehicles and stuff it it like feels
super familiar that way and maybe in the
modern ones but yeah apart from that
it's essentially mobile you're shooting
creep and you're upgrading your person
and yeah so it's it's just we're kind of
yeah it's like if you're super familiar
the minute you start playing it even
though we'd probably never played
something exactly like this before I
mean a lot of the skills kind of
translate you know it's kind of hard to
expand on the world of mobile and skills
right so a lot of things are very
familiar I think I played Gideon his
ultimate is pretty much if anyone's
played dota 2 it's kind of like you know
ending was black hole right like it just
sucks everything in and it's supposed to
be like something there for like what i
like to say the wombo combo so that you
know your teammates can come in and like
do other abilities and you chain off of
that so it's cool i mean the actions
fine i don't know if it was just kidding
for me that felt a little slow i know
that his shift mechanic let him kind of
like speed up a little bit but i don't
use that in combat that's kind of like
your mechanic to kind of get back and
forth a little bit faster outside of
like teleporting the airbase yes we're
to you hold down shift while there's
nothing about holding they shift the
wrong be holding shift to like engage
travel mode and i guess the the sort of
the negative part of that is that if you
get caught if you give somebody like
catches you on the way in and hits you
while you're in java mode you get stuck
for like a couple of seconds right and
they could just like pound on you for a
while yeah cuz if you come out of it
manually it's pretty fast if you
actually like um I just started figuring
out if I just activate one of my I had a
leap power I like mayhem he's which
traditionally I don't really like tank
characters but for whatever reason this
kind of game I do he has a leaping
attack and I would just press that and
it would immediately get me out of the
travel mode give me an extra like 30
feet so it's kind of a good combo but
yeah if you date someone else interrupts
it then you're kind of like screwed for
two seconds or so and that's what's cool
about this in terms of because it that
MOBAs our games of inches right it's
like how its understanding the range of
your opponents understanding the range
of your attacks and how best you can do
it and what I've really enjoyed about
this is that like the battles I've been
having like again smelly people and or
maybe I'm like a dude with like two
pistols right he's like shooting people
he's pretty one
good starter characters and he has this
sort of one of his power ups you can
upgrade is like a leap which can give
you like a but you know 10 feet on the
other person and I've been playing these
people who've been like using melee like
swings at me and just barely missing me
and I'm like jumping out of the way like
like by you know it's like skimming me
and then everyone saw seeing the
cooldown on this little leap attack
turning around using it to get away and
then just like pounding on them yeah
it's like it's and it's fun it like it
feels like oh that's what I see when I
see people play like really you know
good level doderer lawl but this is
actually in a game that I would play
like I like okay so first oyster
shooters in third person Jews that was
kind of where I was headed next I guess
because MOBAs are kind of a thing that
you know they were on the rise right and
then they kind of plateaued a little bit
because there's just three heavy hitters
that you can't really get by you know
and then now you know smite probably the
first one to be kind of successful in
like a third person mode so it's
interesting to hear that you're actually
more willing to play a game like Paragon
knowing that to MOBA because maybe it
just has unreal roots or something yeah
like cuz I went back in like I never
really played much Smosh and I went back
over the past couple days like watch a
bunch of smite again just see like first
of all that game like I think it only
came out like two years ago i think it
was like april 2014 well maybe that was
like the final version but it just it
looks it looks super aged yeah in a way
that like the feed but this game first
of all looks good but also the feedback
you get on when you're hitting people is
like you know you need you know you need
that in games like this you need to be
able to be like okay like in the
division that you feel the numbers
coming off them you know in your attacks
line then you know and you get that like
really good feedback from the game and
this game has that really well which I
enjoy about it so I was like encouraged
to go around and try different here I
don't what the call in the column here
is why not and you could because of that
feedback visually or audio or whatever
it is f you also like for instance
looking at the the gameplay here of the
various other attacks during the game
you kind of pick up on what exactly all
that stuff is doing really quickly
whereas watching all the smite footage I
was like oh yeah I get like if you put
the time and you figure it out but like
it wasn't that immediate thing and when
you're talking about a game with all of
these heroes and all of these different
ways of playing that stuff can get super
intimidating like we'd overwatch like
that's in our game that sells it really
well this gives us
have that many heroes though it feels
like it looks like 12 12 I wouldn't be
shocked if there's gonna be like more
though you write like this alpha you
know you can always build you can always
have more right like that's how you just
get people to keep buying characters yes
often during the preview event I had I
had asked an epic said they plan on
doing a lot of post-release stuff which
is which suits this the nature of these
games well and that's the thing like it
all these games like you had said that
melange it's kind of actually I was I'm
about as lukewarm as you can be when it
comes to like battle born overwatch I
was having fun with everything in the
new Paragon but and I wouldn't say I'm
like extremely excited about any of them
but they I am coming around to the idea
and like coming around to the fact that
oh these games all just kind of add that
that reflexive like quick reaction thing
to the overall strategy which I like
strategy and I like shooters those are
both like two of my main backgrounds
like like kind of just starting to
realize the potential of combining those
especially when we can talk more about
battleborn i'm looking forward that i
can't speak to the overall quality of
battle born but it does do some stuff
like interesting things and then
overwatch is doing its own thing Paragon
is doing its own thing and I'm actually
kind of looking forward to seeing all
the different like I don't know
permutations that can come out of
combining these genres I'm coming around
to it really fast but it's excited it's
like the difference between doulton law
right if you're not in that like area
and playing those games like who cares
like II you wouldn't really give a [ __ ]
and I feel like these games maybe it's
just personal but like I feel like me
and a lot of other people they were all
just cut we didn't know that much better
we haven't played them when it's like oh
they're all kind of doing the same thing
where's now they are they all completely
it's completely different piece like
overwatch I love for loads of different
reasons yeah like it feels more like
counter-strike to me obviously this is
nothing like that game that even though
I was pulling them in together yeah and
the same kind of thing I think my I
don't know expectation means a lot my
expectation of Paragon wasn't too I it's
a God's free to play third person mobile
thing it's coming out this year but I'd
encourage people to play it like I was
like I played a game which lasted 40
minutes and went straight into played
another one and like that doesn't happen
with me and MOBAs so yeah definitely
recommend is it plays playstation 4 pc
is what the current authors in there and
doing some sort of paid alpha apparently
yeah you can so i was trying it last
night where I don't call me on the day
because I think that's right I haven't
slept very well lot of sins but i think
it's
318 if you buy you get into the
founder's pack and I think the cheapest
one twenty dollars so i think you'll
have access in like a couple days if you
uh if you just at least spend the twenty
or whatnot but what's some money go on
why is it because they games free to
play and examine the summertime i'm sure
i didn't again i didn't look at all the
details yet but I'm sure it's like a
card pack thing or maybe like a skin
pack because there are like you can see
that there's like a drop down for like
do you want to pick normal Gideon or you
know your normal hero or like a
variation you're here so i wouldn't be
shocked if its skin related or maybe a
card pack thing something that hopefully
doesn't alter the like gameplay like not
a pay to win thing with a cosmetic thing
yeah so I mean yeah I couldn't hopefully
they know if that is not we could do
with these games yeah the balance would
just feed trash if they did that right
yeah i totally i do have any previews up
on the side of a park yeah there's one
just about how like epics past with
action games it's influenced it um
there's about a week or two ago some
some headline like that i don't remember
exactly yeah I had a pretty positive
experience with it sweet if you want to
learn more about paragon go to gamespot
com look up that thing that Mike just
told you bad google it I don't know do
the work we haven't figured out a way of
sending video links yet let's just do it
yourself and let us know if your instant
park on if you're not in paragon if we
gonna check out the beta ps4 or pc let
us know in the comments below
you